la ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé l'invité de preuves par 3
marisol touraine bonsoir bonsoir et
merci de votre présence à ce rendez-vous
de public sénat avec dailymotion et l'
agence france presse qui sera représenté
ce soir par hervé lloret spécialiste des
questions sociales donc de la réforme
des retraites les syndicats même
réformiste d'ailleurs demande appelle
les députés à améliorer encore le texte
ne nous en parlerons et puis avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
parlerons de santé publique alors que
vous venez présenter une nouvelle
stratégie pour lutter contre les
inégalités avec notamment la gratuité
chez le médecin votre ministère madame
touraine est très vaste à la fois très
technique mais très proche également des
préoccupations des français es ce que
vous avez l'impression d'être depuis que
vous êtes à ce poste atteinte de
gestion' it aiguë vous l'avez dit c'est
un des ministères qui est le plus en
prise avec la réalité quotidienne de la
vie des français et moi j'ai depuis un
an
la fierté d'avoir engagé des politiques
qui concernent les français au quotidien
qu'il s'agisse d'améliorer leurs
remboursements de permettre la gratuité
d'olive et j'ai de permettre la gratuité
de la contraception pour les mineures de
faire en sorte que la sécurité des
médicaments soient renforcés c'est ce
que nous avons fait pour la pilule par
exemple cela c'est la vie quotidienne
des français comme très concrètement la
revalorisation de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire ou évidemment en ce
moment la réforme des retraites qui
concerne chacun d'entre nous viennent
entendu donc claude bartolone parce que
c'est lui qui a poussé ce coup de gueule
devant les parlementaires socialistes
la gestionnaire aiguë ça suffit en fait
ils utilisent le gouvernement vous êtes
ministre de simplement administrer les
choses et donc de vous piéger vous même
le gouvernement depuis un peu plus d'un
an qu'il est aux responsabilités il a un
cap celui de la transformation à gauche
la transformation à gauche de notre
société répondre aux attentes des
français
le mariage pour tous ça n'est pas de la
gestion c'est une réforme profonde
la réforme des retraites que je porte
aujourd'hui
cela répond à des réalités et
j'entends de la part de nos concitoyens
ja oui je pourrais énumérer lors que je
veux dire par là c'est que nous avons un
cap ce cap c'est celui de la
transformation
c'est l'obsession de l'emploi
l'obsession de la croissance faire en
sorte que nos concitoyens vivent mieux
claude bartolone vous estimez qu'il ya
le débat est trop intense sur la pause
ou la non pause fiscale donc en quelque
sorte c'est ça mais le fait que jean
marc ayrault donc assume les os il le
dit lui même
mais augmenter et augmenter les impôts
madame au notw est-ce que c'est du
courage les impôts c'est un moyen
si nous avions pu ne pas augmenter les
impôts nous l'aurions fait mais nous
avons dû à notre arrivée aux
responsabilités mettre en place une
politique qui est aussi passé par de la
fiscalité mais pas uniquement par de la
fiscalité parce qu'aujourd'hui le débat
se concentre sur les impôts mais je veux
rappeler qu' il y a eu aussi des
économies importantes réalisées et la
mise en place d'une politique de soutien
à la compétitivité des entreprises c'est
par cet assortiment de mesures si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi que nous relançons
la croissance que nous relançons la
croissance et l'activité pour l'emploi
et les premiers résultats sont là donc
il ne s'agit pas de nier qu'il y a eu
des augmentations d'impôts d'ailleurs
ils sont là les melons mais aujourd'hui
et le président de la république l'a
indiqué la part des économies va être
plus importante et au four l'objectif
que nous nous fixons il reste le même la
croissance et l'emploi et ne faisons pas
de cette question des impôts la seule
question qui serait celle de la
politique que nous suivons assumer la
baisse des dépenses ça c'est plus
glorieux c'est plus et plus courageux en
tous les cas ce sera sans doute plus
difficile néanmoins sur une question
savez ça n'est pas facile de présenter
des hausses de fiscalité encore une fois
c'est nous pouvions éviter si nous
avions pu éviter certaines hausses de
fiscalité nous l'aurions fait face à
seulement les économies elle porte aussi
sur des politiques auquel les français
sont attachés donc il faut avoir
conscience que nous sommes dans une
période qui appelle des efforts efforts
fiscaux
efforts en matière de taux n'est pas
aussi fort de m d'ailleurs l'ensemble de
l'administration d'état fait des efforts
tout à fait important puisque les
économies sur le budget de l'état seront
historiques et celle des collectivités
locales aussi point précis vous avez
assumé pour reprendre l'expression du
premier ministre la réduction du
quotient familial est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer que des familles vont
finalement gardé leurs réductions
d'impôts pour leurs enfants scolarisés à
partir du secondaire
le ministre de l'économie des finances
présentera le projet de loi de finances
demain au classement c'est une île à il
a dit ce matin de façon extrêmement
clair que cela ferait partie du débat au
parlement et rigueur le parlement pourra
exprimer ce qu'est sa priorité ou sa
préoccupation
les débats au parlement doivent être
ouverts nous avons nous avons une double
exigence qui est celle de permettre
parlementaire de jouer leur rôle qui est
celui de relayer des préoccupations et
de porter des améliorations aux textes
que nous présentons est en même temps de
garantir que l' équilibre des textes que
nous présentons est respectée parce
qu'évidemment nous construisons nous
construisons des réformes qui est dont
l'esprit est l' équilibre doit être
respecté l'accord attendant ce débat non
pour savoir si effectivement vont
renoncer
pour les familles c'est sur quoi je veux
affronter ici c'est que la politique
familiale du gouvernement est une
politique forte et ambitieuse
l'autre politique elle ne consiste pas
seulement à réorienter les ressources en
direction des familles les plus modestes
même si je veux insister sur le fait que
en baissant l'aide fiscale aux familles
les plus aisées nous allons pouvoir
renforcer yeux et se sentent aujourd'hui
oui tu savais
l'aide nous nous renforçons l'aide aux
familles modestes et en particulier aux
familles nombreuses mais nous aidons
toutes les familles à travers une
politique résolue de d'accueil du jeune
enfant de l'enfant de moins de 3 ans et
cela c'est une politique qui s'adresse
aussi aux familles des classes moyennes
parce que nous savons que la
conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
cela concerne l ensemble des femmes
répudiées d'ensemble des femmes vous
avez cité françois hollande est jamais
sa popularité n'avait été aussi bas
c'est ce que cela vous inquiète
la popularité je les ai souvent dit on
préfère qu'elle soit élevé peut être
faible mais la priorité pour un
président la république pour un
gouvernement se dé répondre aux
exigences de l'intérêt général et aux
exigences du pays la situation de crise
dans laquelle se trouve notre pays
appelle des mesures courageuses résolu
qui ne sont pas nécessairement populaire
et c'est cela que fait le président la
république et je sais que sa
préoccupation c'est de permettre à notre
pays d'aller de l'avant ça n'est pas de
se préoccuper de l'état de sa popularité
bien sûr le soleil mais l'essentiel
c'est que au bout du mandat
la france a et mieux les français soient
plus sûrs d'eux mêmes plus à même
d'affronter l'avenir c'est cela
l'exigence qui pèse sur les épaules
jeudi françois mitterrand vous savez le
précédent président de la république
était très obsédé par sa courbe de
popularité
à l'évidence cela n'a pas permis de
convaincre les français la ministre de
la santé il a formulé médical je les lui
dans le figaro qui ne ménage pas ses
critiques certes mais la greffe ne prend
pas il ya un rejet du chef de l'état
écrit ce journal
encore une fois l'exigence de mesures
difficiles courageuses s'impose
l'exigence pour nous c'est de répondre
aux préoccupations des français de faire
en sorte que année après année mois
après mois si possible mais année après
année eh bien la france et les français
à mieux notamment sur le terrain du
chômage
et puisque le président s'est engagé à
ce que la courbe du chômage s'est ain
vers d'ici la fin de l'année
c'est un objectif pour nous tous et il
faut souligner que d'ores et déjà la
courbe du chômage des jeunes s'est
inversée depuis plusieurs mois c'est un
point important et qui est porteur
d'espoir parler du courage et chef de
l'état est ce que vous diriez la même
chose à propos de vos collègues manuel
valls qui estime que les roms dans leur
majorité ne veulent pas s'intégrer en
france en raison de leur mode de vie
vous avez vous vu le même avertit public
c'est à la fois des valeurs et des
règles et nous devons rappeler à la fois
les valeurs de la république et les
règles de cette règle pour les roms ceux
qui vivent sur notre territoire doivent
respecter les règles lorsque de la
république française lorsque ça n'est
pas le cas ils sont évidemment amené à
quitter notre territoire mais nous
devons avoir une politique question est
est-ce que par essence
les roms ont vocation à quitter notre
pays est d'accord mais les roms doivent
respecter les règles de la république
il ne s'agit pas il ne s'agit pas de
mode de vie il ne s'agit pas de
différence
il ya une incapacité à s'intégrer sur
notre territoire
il y à des hommes et des femmes qui tous
n'ont pas les mêmes modes de vie mais
qui tous doivent respecter les règles de
la république
et lorsqu'il ne les respectent pas ils
doivent quitter notre territoire et les
roms sont dans cette situation là s'ils
respectent les règles ils peuvent rester
sur notre terre serait une minorité
selon ces insectes les règles et une
minorité jeudi là l'enjeu il est celui
du respect des règles la république
ce sont des règles c'est aussi des
valeurs et je crois que nous devons
avoir le respect des personnes et le
respect des valeurs et des règles de
l'autre réclame vous êtes tout à l'heure
vous mettez du côté des associations qui
s'indignent qui dénoncent ces
stéréotypes ou
entre gêne opinion manuel valls il a dit
à la fois qu'il y avait le respect des
règles et qu' il y avait une intégration
à possible dans leur majorité les roms
doivent partir car elles ne peuvent pas
s'intégrer dans la république mais ceux
qui s'intègrent et respectent les règles
n'ont pas à être mis en cause et je ne
crois pas que cela puisse être l'esprit
de ce qu'a dit le ministre de
l'intérieur en tous les cas il soulève
une polémique elle est infondée pour
vous la polémique n'a pas lieu d'être
dès lors que l'on rappelle dès lors que
l'on rappelle que on se fixe par rapport
aux règles de la république il ne s'agit
pas de considérer que telle ou telle
population par principe ne respectent
pas les règles simplement en semaine la
situation de constater si les règles de
la république sont bien respectés encore
une fois tout le monde souhaite que
l'ordre soit évidemment sanctuariser et
en même temps cela doit s'accompagner
d'une grande humanité et du respect des
valeurs de notre république notre
république elle est accueillante
dès lors on accepte que c'était un peu
différent quand même de cette de votre
collègue question rapide est ce qu'il
faut changer la loi pour faciliter le
travail la nuit dans certains magasins
je fais référence à la fermeture décidée
par la justice du magasin sephora sur
les champs elysées oui aux articles de
changement de loi je ne suis pas
certaine il doit y avoir des discussions
des négociations lorsque c'est jugé
nécessaire entre les entreprises et
leurs salariés
mais ne faisons pas comme si la nouvelle
règle devait être de travailler le plus
possible tout plus tard possible et
disons le plus longtemps que la corde on
va parler du travail dans un instant
avec la réforme des retraites est ce
qu'il faut donner le droit de vote aux
élections locales
à 16 ans et votre ministre de la famille
madame bertinotti silence libe dominique
bertinotti a indiqué qu'un groupe de
travail était en train de réfléchir à
cette perspective je crois qu'il faut
être prudent pour ce qui est de
l'ouverture du droit de vote la
réflexion est engagée et nous verrons
bien si elle peut aboutir
ou d'en être prudent et parce que pascal
à 16 ans c'est vrai on peut peut-être
avoir un statut de pré majorité en sont
les droits liés à la pré majorité
puisque il est des situations dans
lesquelles on reconnaît une pré majorité
par exemple en matière de sexualité
et donc voilà donc il ya plusieurs âges
qui sont différents et c'est la raison
pour laquelle une réflexion est engagée
pour savoir s'il peut faire l'amour à 15
ans on ne peut pas voter en 18 oui
écoutez donc la réflexion est engagée
encore une fois moi je souhaite que cela
se fasse avec prudence on n'est pas sûr
donc cette mesure figurera dans la
prochaine
la réflexion n'est pas à ce stade à bout
nicolas sarkozy reste mis en examen dans
le volet abus de faiblesse de l'affairé
bettencourt alors entendu en haute
savoie il annoncé qu'il avait en tête un
calendrier politique de retour beaucoup
de ténors de l'ump dénonce un
acharnement
est ce que vous pensez à ce que vous
espérez que son retour butera sur un
obstacle judiciaire
la justice fait son travail elle est
indépendante et moi je n'espère rien je
n'attends rien en la matière nicolas
sarkozy décidera si il souhaite se
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
ou à une autre élection mais en tout cas
le calendrier judiciaire il est
indépendant et il n'appartient pas
d'interférer avec ce cadeau d'un
acharnement les juges je moi je ne
commente pas les décisions de justice je
ne vois pas pourquoi les décisions de
justice arrangerait dans certains cas et
et contreviendrait à certains plans dans
d'autres on trouve toujours matière à se
réjouir ou à se désoler des décisions de
justice donc le mieux c'est de ne pas
les commenter et de laisser la justice
en toute indépendance faire son travail
les lyonnais donc de l'agencé france
presse va nous rejoindre maintenant pour
parler de la réforme des retraites que
vous portez marisol touraine sous les
critiques à on va reparler d'ailleurs
des hausses d'impôts du moins des
prélèvements pour le financer et on l'a
vu sondages encore
le scepticisme l'emportent dans
l'opinion alors voici une nouvelle
réforme des retraites pas encore la
réforme
sophie normand mini réforme maxi
cotisation c'est en substance la
critiques assénées par les détracteurs
de la réforme des retraites version
héros au coeur du projet de loi il y à
bien une hausse des prélèvements
ils seront progressifs et toucheront
salariés des employeurs le financement
du régime général passera aussi par un
allongement de la durée de cotisation au
rythme d'un trimestre tous les trois ans
en 2035
il faudra donc travailler 43 ans pour
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
le dispositif concernera les salariés du
public et du privé mais pas avant 2020
pour eric woerth ancien ministre de
nicolas sarkozy père de la réforme des
retraites de 2010 le gouvernement manque
de courage et a pas de courage du tout
ce contrat à l'exercice de lâcheté
politique formidable et c'est pas une
référence et une augmentation des taxes
si une augmentation des taxes et
réformer le système des retraites
en tout cas essayer de régler les
problèmes financiers des retraites
uniquement par des cotisations
c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment un
train à côté de la plaque avancée
sociale majeure la création d'un conte
pénibilité les salariés qui auront
exercé un métier difficile pourront dès
2015 accumuler des points et partir
plutôt une mesure qui s'additionnent aux
dérogations qui existe déjà pour les
invalidités par exemple ou plus
récemment les salariés qui ont commencé
à travailler avant 20 ans et qui
pourront s'arrêter à 60 ans à la fin de
la décennie
c'est ainsi un salarié sur deux qui
pourra techniquement partir en retraite
avant 62 ans et ce avec une pension
complète des exceptions qui viennent
s'ajouter à des prévisions de chômage
déjà très optimiste entre 5 et 7% alors
même que la france n'est pas revenu en
dessous d'eux
8 ou 9% depuis très longtemps et que les
prévisions ne l'anticipent à une baisse
du taux de chômage rapide sceptiques
aussi la commission européenne c'est
avec méfiance que les réformes à la
française sont suivis par vos selles ou
le président de la commission josé
manuel barroso table lui sur un départ
en retraite à 65 ans voilà c'est ce
qu'ils recommandent donc le président de
la commission européenne à vos questions
sur cette réforme qui serait encore plus
âprement débattus dans quelques jours au
parlement pas marisol touraine
oui madame la ministre cette réforme a
d'abord un objectif financier celui de
combler un déficit on parlait de 20
milliards en 2020 si on ne faisait rien
mais on se rend compte que finalement
vous combler le déficit essentiellement
du régime général c'est à dire un peu
plus de 7 milliards
alors pour les 13 autres milliards d'ici
2020 comment fait-on cette réforme n'a
pas simplement un objectif financier
cette réforme elle a la volonté
d'apporter un horizon et des
perspectives aux générations qui
s'engagent dans la vie active ou sont au
milieu de leur vie active parce que si
nous ne faisons rien alors nous ouvrons
un grand la porte à la privatisation de
notre système ou en tout cas à une
partie de notre système et donc c'est
une réforme qui a un enjeu financier
parce que il faut avoir le courage de
dire que nous devons trouver des
ressources pour garantir dans l'avenir
le financement de nos régimes de
retraite
mais c'est aussi une réforme qui a un
objectif de rééquilibrage en termes de
justice de notre système de retraite
parce qu'il n'est pas juste que la
situation des femmes soit à ce point
dégradée par rapport à celle des hommes
parce qu'il n'est pas juste que les
conditions de travail ne soient pas
prises en compte pour définir le mode de
départ en retraite et donc non je
travaille les coups et les coups de
fouet en avant
le précédent mais le précédent
gouvernement a mis en avant la notion
d'invalidité et lorsque j'entendais eric
woerth je me disais que puisqu'il
parlait de mots comme lâcheté ou autre
qu' il ne manquez pas d'air si vous me
passez l'expression un peu triviale
parce que ce qui a caractérisé sa
réforme c'est le mépris mépris des
français en particulier de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler jeunes mépris de
ceux qui sont usés par le travail
puisqu'au fond il a mis en place une
commission qui regardent le dossier
médical des gens et leur permet ou pas
de partir en retraite plus tôt mais
l'invalidité
ça n'a jamais été une situation où deux
pénibilités et c'est toute la différence
que d'ailleurs souligner les
organisations à syndicale entre
l'invalidité et la pénibilité mais moi
je veux répondre à votre question sur
les la situation financière en 2020 on a
beaucoup évoqué ce chiffre de 20
milliards et il est juste c'est celui du
conseil d'orientation des retraites mais
il est global c'est-à-dire qu'il
comporte notamment tout ce qui a trait
au régime complémentaire de retraite qui
comme vous le savez ne dépendent pas du
gouvernement mais des partenaires
sociaux et la réforme que nous
présentons elle permet de financer le
régime général mais elle permet aussi
d'apporter des ressources nécessaires à
haut régime des fonctionnaires puisque
ils ont un régime différent de celui des
salariés du privé et c'est la raison
pour laquelle ans et c'est la raison
pour laquelle tu régimes spéciaux j'aime
spéciaux non mais les régimes spéciaux
c'est un régime des médecins aussi par
c'est à dire la caisse
régime on trouve de nouvelles ressources
pour l'ensemble des régimes je veux
insister là dessus puisque la hausse des
cotisations elle va concerner aussi les
fonctionnaires et les salariés des
régimes spéciaux
là le report de la revalorisation de la
retraite l'année prochaine
des retraités va concerner les retraités
de la fonction publique ceux des régimes
spéciaux comme ceux d une citation me
prime estimations le nous allons à
l'équilibré en 2020 et en 2035 qui sont
les deux horizons que nous avons fixés
dans l'ensemble des régimes je veux
insister sur ce point parce que même si
des règles différentes continue
d'exister entre les différents régimes
l'effort qui est demandé à l'ensemble
des français est le même
il n'y a pas des français qui ne
participent pas à l'effort collectif
demandé pour la sauvegarde de nos
retraites à l'avenir on palais de
monsieur eric woerth tout à l'heure
c'est vrai que vous tapez beaucoup sur
la réforme de 2010 mais beaucoup sur la
nôtre oui enfin si je crois que vous
avez commencé puisque puisque ces mêmes
est néanmoins elle vous êtes quand même
pas mal parce que enfin lui dit que sans
cette réforme le recul de l'âge de 60 à
62 ans ça serait non pas 20 milliards
que deux
de déficit à combler d'ici 2020 mais 50
milliards merci finalement souviens très
précisément c'est ce que disait le
précédent gouvernement lorsqu'il a
présenté sa réforme en 2010 et je ne
m'en souviens puisque effectivement
j'étais responsable pour le parti
socialiste à l'époque dans l'opposition
de mener 30 milliards non parce que ils
nous disaient zéro déficit en 2020 sa
réforme
elle prétendait combler le trou des
régimes de retraite
la crise est aggravée en quelques mois
en quelques mois nous nous sommes
aperçus que les résultats n'étaient pas
là puisque dès 2011
il a fallu indiqué que des efforts
seraient nécessaires et une nouvelle
réforme s'imposerait donc je crois que
mon donneur de leçons monsieur woerth
n'est pas crédible parce que pour donner
des leçons il faut d'abord avoir des
résultats et les résultats il manque
cruellement au gouvernement précédent
alors cette réforme madame la ministre
est aussi une réforme que vous voulez
juste et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
mesures de justice mais pourtant je
voudrais vous interroger sur quelques
petits points qui me qui me pose
question par exemple ce conte pénibilité
quand vous êtes artisan ou que vous avez
simplement un ou deux salariés vous fait
le même travail mais vous n'êtes pas
considéré comme salarié donc vous pouvez
pas ouvrir de comptes pénibilité la
pénibilité concerne les salariés pas les
professions libérales qui ont la
possibilité de documents sur l'ubs
erreurs mais qui ont la possibilité de
définir leurs conditions de travail
l'objectif de ce conte de prévention de
la pénibilité c'est quoi c'est de faire
en sorte que celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé dans des conditions identifié
comme étant pénibles puissent avoir des
contreparties par exemple en se formant
au cours de leur carrière pour changer
de métier ou en partant plus tôt à la
retraite parce qu'ils sont usés mais ça
aussi pour objectif de d'amener les
entreprises et les chefs d'entreprises
donc par exemple les artisans à changer
les conditions de travail dans
lesquelles ils évoluent et c'est pour
cela que les autres
l'organisme a contribué ou simplement
avec un seul ou avec un ou deux salariés
ils pourront plus facilement c'est en
général ce qui se passe transformer
leurs conditions de travail et adapter
la façon dont ils réalisent leur
production voilà pour les artisans
oui alors peut-être un autre petit point
aussi de justice comment peut-on
expliquer que un retraité très aisé à
quitte finalement une une csg de 6,6
pour cent et qu'un actif très jeune au
smic lui il acquitte 7,5
là vous évoquez il y a une qui ne
concerne pas la réforme des retraites
c'est le débat de la qualité de façon à
répondre ce que c'est une question qui
vient régulièrement mais je pense la
luxure graffeurs moreau pour une fois
c'est une proposition parmi d'autres
encore font attention à ne pas donner le
sentiment que au fond il s'agissait
d'additionner l'ensemble des mesures du
rapport - madame moreau et sa commission
avait identifié cette piste là mais
auquel cas nous n'aurions pas fiscalisés
les compléments de retraite lorsque l'on
a plus de trois enfants ou reporter la
revalorisation de la retraite de six
mois au fond la question et je suis
frappé de voir que pour une fois on nous
demande d'augmenter un impôt puisque
cela revenait augmenter ce taux de le
module de csg ça revenait à augmenter 1
un pot de fer contre les retraités comme
et comme positive
les organisations syndicales et c'est le
choix d'ailleurs que nous avons fait
c'est de faire porter l'effort sur les
cotisations et donc de cibler l'effort
des retraités sur le report de leur
revalorisation
d'ailleurs les petites retraites cinéma
mais la question de la csg pourra être
évoqué le cas échéant à d'autres
occasions mais au fond nous avons c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'évoque certains du
côté des organisations syndicales je ne
sais pas si ce serait le choix du
gouvernement nous n'avons pas avancé
suffisamment dans nos décisions pour que
je puisse vous répondre mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les décisions sont
cohérentes on additionne pas des mesures
les unes aux autres de la cotisation
pour les actifs de la csg pour les
retraités
donc nous avons fait le choix de nous
concentrer sur les cotisations qui sont
identifiés comme étant le mode de
financement classiques directement
madame la ministre
il est question de compenser pour 2014
la hausse des cotisations des
entreprises
comment faites vous vous avez déjà
refusé toute nouvelle aux le cg ou de
tva donc sera confirmé d'ailleurs demain
à l'occasion de la présentation du
budget nous nous sommes engagés à ce
qu'il n'y ait ni hausse de tva
supplémentaire ni hausse de csg commun
qu'il s'agit de financer la politique
familiale cela se fera sur le budget de
l'état c'est à dire à travers la
politique budgétaire des économies qui
sont fait écouter les économies qui sont
faites ailleurs les ressources qui sont
appelés à la fiscalité déjà prévu et qui
nous permet de financer nos politiques
familiales nous permettront de finances
nous qui sont prévus pour le budget de
l'état pardon nous permettront de
financer la politique familiale
compensation de l'os ne demande
absolument pas deux il n'y a pas de
hausse dédié pour cette politique
familiale où allez vous trouver cet
argent dans les économies que nous
faisons et qui sont très importantes
vous le savez nous avons annoncé 15
milliards d'économies c'est passionnel
au président cherchait le budget oui
mais ça fait partie du budget de l'état
donc l'état s'engage à garantir le
maintien de la politique familiale bien
évidemment à hauteur de ce qu'elle est
et à faire les économies nécessaires
paris hier pour financer cette petite
réponse serait pas de compensation sous
forme de hausses d'impôts voilà qui est
dit là alors merci avec l'année dernière
question vous avez vanté l'action du
parlement tout à l'heure en matière de
fiscalité marisol touraine
est ce que par exemple on compter sur le
parlement pour améliorer votre réforme
sur les retraites puisque c'est ce que
demandent notamment les syndicats la
cfdt qui veut des réformes de justice va
avoir lieu
des améliorations peuvent évidemment
être introduite dès lors que comme je
les dis tous les jeunes pour le musulman
dit tout à l'heure il s'agit de faire en
sorte que l'équilibré financier et
social de la retraite pour soit
préservée que son équilibre ne soient
pas bousculés très bien débat à suivre à
partir du mois d'octobre
merci encore une fois hervé le 7 octobre
effectivement ça l'assemblée nationale
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoint maintenant donc pour la
troisième partie de cette émission qui
consacré à la santé à la santé publique
puisque vous venez de présenter madame
la ministre votre nouvelle stratégie
nationale de santé avec comme points
forts l'instauration du tiers payant
chez le médecin une mesure qui divise la
profession d'ailleurs faustine saint
geniès une simple carte vitale pour
régler sa consultation chez le médecin
ce sera possible pour les patients d'ici
marisol touraine vient de l'annoncer le
tiers-payant s'appliquera chez
l'ensemble des généralistes à la fin du
quinquennat
les patients n'auront alors plus rien à
débourser lors d'une consultation chez
un médecin conventionné
la mesure s'appliquera d'abord aux plus
démunis qui évite souvent de consulter
par manque de moyens une bonne nouvelle
pour ce généraliste à aubervilliers en
seine-saint-denis la précarité augmente
en france les gens se soignent mal
attendent et va finalement livré aux
urgences parce que la lp pas donc en
faisant cela on refera ce que souhaitent
actuellement le
gouvernance et l'autre gouvernance
précédente aussi c'est à dire permettre
aux médecins de proposer la même
configuration de règlement l hôpital et
donc à ce moment là les patients
viendront nous voir sans réticence mais
pour d'autres médecins généraliser le
tiers payant va créer un véritable casse
tête administratif et surtout
déresponsabiliser les patients lorsque
vous supprimez les quais sa sortie d'un
supermarché les calissons certainement
plus rempli que si les gens payent ces
2000 question de bon sens si demain la
gratuité induit une consommation
supérieure alors que nous sommes dans le
cas d'une maîtrise des dépenses
d'assurance maladie a tous eu quand même
d'être inquiet la question est donc de
savoir si le fait de ne rien payer va
pousser à aller davantage chez le
médecin mais ce n'est pas ce qui pèse le
plus sur les comptes de la branche
maladie de la sécurité sociale déjà
déséquilibré pour des raisons
structurelles
il faut revoir la carte hospitalière il
faut revoir notre finalement notre
appareil de production de médicaments
il faut donc traiter le sujet j'allais
dire dans les structures et non pas le
faire à la marge
jeudi prochain le gouvernement
présentera son budget de la sécurité
sociale le déficit de la branche maladie
pourrait atteindre 7 à 8 milliards
d'euros
voilà qu'en même temps avec notamment
soir ministre sur des questions très
diverses de santé nous concerne tous
exactement
marisol touraine relations avec les
médecins était déjà un peu tendus avec
la généralisation du tiers payant est ce
que vous prenez pas de risque de les
braquer une fois de plus je ne crois pas
du tout d'ailleurs
l'accueil est favorable à cette mesure
parce que les médecins savent très bien
que c'est une mesure qui va dans le sens
de l'intérêt des français que les
français la plébiscitent on a souhaité
mais je le soumets michel genson étaient
critiques de la part des médecins et des
tons il énonce une étatisation du
système qui va coûter cher le 3 euros
par acte plus de la gêne pas du tout pas
du tout à cela
nous travaillons maintenant concrètement
à la mise en place de ce dispositif qui
existe dans énormément de pays pour
lesquels dans lesquelles ça ne se
traduit pas par davantage de papiers ou
d'administration pour les professionnels
de santé
je veux rappeler que ça fait partie
des préconisations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé pour garantir
l'accès aux soins de manière simple et
cela doit permettre d' ailleurs à des
français de ne pas aller à l'hôpital où
le tiers-payant existèrent concrètement
on n'avance pas l'argent ça n'est pas
que ce soit gratuit
1 je veux insister là dessus parce que
ça coûte de l'argent ça n'est pas
gratuit
simplement nous n'avance pas on n'a pas
l'air mais c'est ce qui se passe pour
les médicaments aussi un problème sur
les médicaments non puisque les
médicaments doivent être prescrits dans
clones en faut oui mais là ça n'est pas
le fait que vous mettiez votre carte
vitale chez le pharmacien c'est
peut-être le fait qu'on vous en prescrit
trop et je veux dire que dans une
responsabilisation en france des
passionnés ça ça fait partie des
discours habituel que l'on entend aucune
étude ne vient confirmer cela à
l'étranger où le tiers-payant existe
c'est-à-dire concrètement où les
patients allemands des pays bas par
exemple vous et ne font pas la vence du
prix de la consultation on n'a pas
constaté d'augmentation dé consommation
médicale
et puis vous savez aujourd'hui le tiers
payant est déjà pratiqué pour les
bénéficiaires de la cmu et on n'a pas
constaté datation des actes mais en
france ce qui est problématique c'est
peut-être pas les visites chez le
généraliste mais normalement je pense
aux gens les moins favorisés les vides
seules dentiste ou chez l'ophtalmo un
oui mais là ce qui est en jeu c'est de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent trouver
des consultations à 1 tarifs remboursés
par la sécurité sociale c'est pour cela
que j'ai lancé dès l'année dernière
une négociation qui a abouti sur la
maîtrise des dépassements d'honoraires
et je veux rappeler par ailleurs que les
personnes qui ont la cmu ou qui peuvent
avoir la cmu la part dont l'aide à la
complémentaire santé
au total ça fait 10 millions de
personnes ce qui est quand même beaucoup
c'est dix millions de personnes ont la
garantie que elles peuvent avoir une
consultation au tarif sécurité sociale
quel que soit le médecin qu'elles vont
consulter
vous présenterez jeudi marisol touraine
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 est ce que
vous confirmez que le déficit global de
de la sécurité sociale sera inférieur de
1 milliard inférieur à caen à quoi à
l'année précédente
écoutez le déficit de la sécurité
sociale sera meilleur enfin sera donc
moins élevé que celui de l'année
dernière et je dois dire que les données
ms attendant ce recul
oui pendant ce recul est dû pour
l'assurance maladie
voilà autant dans son recul et de façon
beaucoup plus in free gardiennage
maladie et y compris et de façon
beaucoup plus significative que ce que
nous avions escompté lors des
estimations du mois de juin dernier donc
c'est à dire je pense que nous pourrons
annoncer des chiffres encourageants et
satisfaisant mais le déficit de la
branche maladie l'huile augmentant les
chiffres seront présentés samedi je dis
pardon et vous verrez que les données
sont tout à fait encourageants mais
quelle va être votre principal levier
d'action pour réduire le déficit de la
branche maladie
est-ce que ça va être le prix des
médicaments qui va être encore ciblé
cette année la question du médicament
est une question tout à fait importante
vous le disiez tout à l'heure nous
consommons trop de médicaments dans
notre pays on veut dire que nous devons
informer informer les français du fait
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de consommer
autant de médicaments encourager la
prescription et l'achat de médicaments
génériques et faire en sorte que dans
les hôpitaux aussi on prescrivent moins
de médicaments je veux dire tenir 10 et
le free jazz également il y aura des
délais des mesures en direction du prix
des médicaments des l'encouragement au
générique en particulier et je lance
d'ailleurs une campagne d'information
sur la vente par internet des
médicaments puisque cela peut être
donner le sentiment que le médicament
est un produit comme un autre et
favoriser la consommation de médicaments
nous rappeler dans cette campagne que un
médicament n'est pas un produit comme un
autre qu'il faut faire attention à ce
que l'on achète et qu'il ne faut prendre
de médicaments que lorsque c'est
absolument nécessaire dans le prochain
budget est ce que vous renoncé à taxer
le nutella l'aspartame les boissons
énergisantes le vin transformer bref
tout ce qui est mauvais pour la santé ce
que vous renoncez à les taxer ça ne
figurera pas dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale j'ai
eu
occasion de le dire ça n'a jamais fait
partie des projets que j'ai portés et
donc parce que je ne crois pas que nous
résolvions des enjeux majeurs de santé
publique à travers des taxes j'ai
annoncé hier matin jour le comportement
quand même ça change les comportements à
condition de faire payer à condition de
faire partie d'une politique d'ensemble
globale et cohérente
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se
contenter d'avoir des mesures disséminés
qu'ils soient du lait sur les cigarettes
nous avons engagé il ya eu une hausse au
mois de juillet dernier est donc cette
hausse s'accompagne d'une politique
résolue d'explication et de soutien à
ceux qui veulent arrêter de fumer on ne
peut pas dire que la lutte la fiscalité
soit le seul instrument de notre
politique de lutte contre le tabac mais
vous évoquiez la stratégie nationale de
santé que j'ai annoncé hier pour la
première fois nous mettons en place dans
notre pays une politique qui fait
globale et qui fait de la prévention la
prévention elle commence à l'école c'est
l'éducation à la santé c'est se fixer
des objectifs de santé publique et c'est
permettre aux médecins d'être rémunéré
pour améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens par des actions de
prévention est donc ça c'est tout à fait
nouveau je veux insister là dessus c'est
ce que font d'ailleurs d'autres pays
c'est ce qu' ils avons pour notre part
jamais engagé alors justement concernant
des comportements en france plusieurs
questions assez précises quand par
exemple va entrer en vigueur
l'interdiction de vapoter dans les lieux
publics je parle de la cigarette
électronique
je ne peux pas répondre précisément une
étude une consultation a été engagée
auprès des hautes et des hautes
instances juridiques de notre pays pour
voir les conditions et les délais dans
lesquels ça peut intervenir mais je suis
prêt si vous visitez
je veux dire à nos concitoyens qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux à utiliser
la cigarette électronique ça n'est pas
un produit anodin et ça fait un peu chic
et choc
la cigarette électronique on voit qu'il
ya un marketing très important autour de
ce produit
ça peut aider à arrêter de fumer et donc
dans c'est pour ça que je n'ai jamais
préconisé l'interdiction de la cigarette
électronique
contrairement à d'autres pays qui l'ont
purement et simplement interdites mais
ça n'est pas un produit comme un autre
et donc arrêté oui façon servir pour
arrêter de fumer oui mais ça peut
inciter des jeunes en particulier qui
trouvent que c'est joli que c'est un peu
tendance ça peut les inciter à venir au
tabac parce que l'état nicotine et la
nicotine
elle rend dépendants je ne sais pas si
vous avez vu marisol touraine ces
révélations d'une enquête de que choisir
le vin le vin il ya eu 92 20 tester ils
étaient tous très contaminée aux
pesticides des vins à tous les prix bio
ou pas bio est ce que jean bourdeau un
voyage quelques cargos
on va pas les citer étude n'avait pas vu
c'est une occupante c'est extrêmement
préoccupant et là il ya un enjeu en
termes de consommation et de contrôle
des produits que nous sommes amenés à
consommer parce que personne ne dit
qu'il ne faut pas ou qu'on ne peut pas
boire du vin de façon raisonnable
je crois que les contrôles doivent
évidemment je me permet de détecter les
solutions il faut une réglementation
lourde et fauche il faut que les
producteurs soient transparents sur les
produits qu'ils proposent à la
consommation de nos pays sont moyens
réglementation t6 réglementation est
nécessaire
il y a nous le verrons mais en tout cas
il est bon que la transparence soit
faite c'est un début de prise de
conscience
plusieurs personnalités proches de votre
majorité bossale taurian font leur
entrée au comité national d'éthique les
responsables religieux sont évincés est
ce que vous leur faites payer leur
position hostile au mariage pour tous
sens il ne s'agit pas de faire payer
quoi que ce soit à qui que ce soit non
je le dis il faut que ce comité
consultatif national d'éthique est une
instance importante que nous sollicitons
beaucoup puis je me suis exprimé puisse
exprimer la diversité de la société
française et c'est la diversité des
opinions qui est représenté dans ce
collectif
les l'éthique et les idées et tic
peuvent être portés par des personnes
sensibles religion sans être pour elle
même ou elle-même des religieux je crois
que cette composition reflète bien la
nouvelle composition de ce comité
reflète bien la diversité des
engagements et des dépositions et des
options dans notre pays vous maintenez
les urgences de l'hôtel-dieu ouverte à
paris contre l'avis de l'ap-hp est ce
que c'est pour des raisons électorales
jusqu'aux élections municipales j'ai
indiqué que le projet de tels lieux est
un grand projet que nous avons besoin
ans entre dans le centre de paris de
repenser l'offre de soins c'est ce qui
est engagé
il y a un travail d'évolution qui passe
aussi par la restructuration des
urgences
globalement à paris ce que je souhaite
c'est que cette restructuration
elle se fasse dans la concertation dans
le dialogue et de manière progressive ça
n'est que si nous avons toutes les
assurances nécessaires que nous pouvons
faire évoluer la situation actuelle que
la négociation et la discussion avance
dernière question est oui alors que j'ai
la pause et on revient la politique on a
fini avec toutes les questions de
sa tétine épuisé ses coûts devrait
concerner évidemment à mais on a parlé
tout à l'heure de la réforme des
retraites vous avez critiqué eric woerth
qui s'exprimait dans le reportage
françois fillon s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui devant les parlementaires de
l'ump il était très très dure sur votre
réforme
il a dit vous les socialistes il
s'adresse à vous vous êtes disqualifié
en fait les frais depuis 20 ans car vous
avez refusé toutes les réformes
précédentes il a parlé des deux sièges
vous avez vous estiment disqualifie que
répondez-vous à françois fillon que la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler est
plutôt une semaine au cours de laquelle
françois fillon s'est disqualifiée pour
porter un jugement sur les activités
politiques dans notre pays qu'il
s'agisse de ses propos sur le front
national qu'il s'agisse de ses propos en
russie particulièrement choquant sur la
politique française vis-à-vis de la
syrie ne sont à l'honneur ni de l'ump ni
de françois fillon donc effectivement en
matière de disqualification françois
fillon n'a de leçon à donner à personne
merci encore une fois d'avoir est avec
nous et merci bonsoir à tout ça très
vite on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
notre invité sur la françois rebsamen le
président des sénateurs ps